here with three skinny poolside snacks
that won't bloat and I love that don't
bloat I just want to blow don't blow a
be sharp everybody Abby's getting
married in two and a half weeks and
she's still doing this show amazing yeah
let's talk about the food that you ate
very important right absolutely so I've
got some really great light refreshing
snacks that are super satisfying yeah so
first we have this chicken satay with a
little almond sauce little Thai almond
sauce alright so this is a really great
high protein recipe so it keeps you
feeling satiated so that you can avoid
overdoing it on you know the chip and
the nachos yeah the ice cream so good so
good so we're gonna start with a little
bit of a marinade I've just got some
chicken that I've sliced in some little
kind of strips right we've got a little
bit of light coconut milk going in yeah
it's kind of a Thai kind of inspiration
some lime juice got some ginger here
some fresh ginger I love that flavor so
much so just a touch of coconut sugar I
love the coconut sugar it has that kind
of you know that vacation like feeling
to it
curry powder and some low-sodium tamari
so this is also a totally gluten-free
dairy-free Ravi and everything's on
Maryland on ca yeah and some fish sauce
so this is gonna go in the fridge for
about two hours to marinate and then we
put them on to our soaked wooden skewers
while we soak them because otherwise
it's just like a bonfire going on over
here so how long do you soak them for
like oh you I don't even take that long
for these tiny little guys that you only
takes about you know 20 minutes half an
hour even so these six about five
minutes per side on a medium-high heat
on the grill alright and we're gonna
work on the real belly busting element
over here which is the Thai almond sauce
so I love this maybe I'll just push this
down okay I love this because um almonds
we've got some natural almond butter
here almonds are rich in monounsaturated
fats and studies are suggesting that
these kinds of fats may actually help
prevent belly fat so that we love for
bikinis days and a couple of the almonds
oh yeah plus they've got that fiber at
the protein and nurse also to keep you
fall
yeah so some almond butter some more of
that light coconut milk we've got some
more coconut sugar so a lot of these
ingredients are kind of doing double
duty now there haven't sugar I mean if
people are watching your sugar yeah it's
it's what makes it help
well it's lower on the glycemic index so
it doesn't spike your blood sugar is
much obviously everything in moderation
you don't want to overdo it on even on
the coconut sugar but I like the flavor
and this also is the gluten free tamari
and some of the fish sauce right it's
some sriracha because I like a little
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you just
basically mix it up including me to be
cooked and then we're just gonna finish
this off with a little bit of those
beautiful almonds some green onions so
good there you go and there's what
you're gonna serve by your pool yeah
yeah very easy to that's great okay now
the next thing is watermelon and tomato
gazpacho yeah yeah so I mean we've
probably all had gazpacho tomato
gazpacho lava and so obviously if you're
trying to reduce bloating hydration is
key
so all those kinds of ingredients that
are really hydrating these are really
water rich ingredients so we've got our
Tomatoes we're gonna start with that and
just I just bought a can of crushed
tomatoes you can use fresh cuz I know a
lot of us have you know fresh tomatoes
in our garden this time of year some
watermelon very high in water yeah you
got to try that look how beautiful red
that is so good
so freshing I love long sweet some
cucumber cucumber is ninety-six percent
water so I mean you can't get more about
it at brunch but totally for your friend
some lime juice a little bit of chili
powder so I'm just gonna give this
little pinch cuz I like some heat and
some jalapeno that I've just diced up
and you know if you don't want it spicy
you can always remove the ribs and the
seeds and I got down a little bit
alright so then basically I just pop
this into my food processor get this
nice and smooth
so we've got some here that we've
already pureed right and I like I like a
little textural contrast with my with my
gazpacho
so I've diced up a little bit more of
that watermelon means more cucumber I
love that and a lot of us are growing
cucumbers now so this is a great way to
use that up whoops and that will just
make do with that some little lime juice
I'm sorry
okay exactly we can we can make sure
that no problem okay point when you're
making these kinds of snacks for the
pool and there's a few it's a little
thing going on there so it's the lime
juice ever and you're gonna do your job
right on top so pretty so good and not
they oughta cut it also has those
monounsaturated fats that again are
really good that we talked away that
looks good that looks really good and
then we're gonna make cucumber lime
granita yeah ronita so it's kind of a
like like a sorbet but I've got more
about this crystalline ice like a ice
crystal flaky consistency right really
satisfying and perfect for a hot summer
day because we need something sweet you
need something cool after all those guys
in here with no shirts on right we gotta
cool things down a little bit you guys
okay yeah all right so we start much the
same way
lots of cucumber and usually I use some
English cucumber because we've got a
little less seeds right but if you don't
if you have filled cucumbers growing in
your garden that you want to use just
scrape out some of the seeds sure it's
really easy so all that goes in there so
much looks so fresh doesn't so fresh and
it's you know what even if spawn you get
spa water yeah it just feels so much
more indulgent yeah and just regular old
water then when we cut our own yeah
exact I don't really like this Bob
exactly so lots of lime juice sure to
keep it nice and fresh
okay and I use mango because mangoes so
naturally sweet you don't have to add
that much sugar to it so I love that
we've got some more jalapeno and because
I like that a kick yeah but to balance
things out we've got some it's also got
some mint just to balance out okay yeah
and a little bit of maple syrup so we
got that in there just attached just
wanted to do maple syrup
I just really like the flavor but again
any kind of sweetener you have it's only
like two tablespoons so it's very Airy
today very exactly okay it to the
Heritage oh there we go so again this
gets nice and pureed yeah and all I do
is pour it into a baking dish I've got
one ready to go over here and basically
you pop it into the freezer every 20
minutes or so just take it out give it a
little scrape we've got that's what we
put in here a little scrape until you
get those kind of crunchy flaky crust
okay so absolutely satisfying very good
thank you good luck with your wedding I
can't wait to see the picture everybody